and we're aboard the drum there but
Lauren's a intervent you here check out
this new weapon I mean I think this is
what everyone was been asking about
lately and sword show me sword so there
you guys go i'm showing shown the sword
yes so this is one of many swords in the
game obviously this is an exotic version
of the sword it's a solar attack and you
can see from the fiction at the top here
these are these are earned so you'll go
on quest to get these they don't drop in
the world can't buy them camp by and we
have to get your hands on them you have
to figure out how to do that there are
several different versions of those two
to play around with so and we're
definitely to play around them today
then we arc shotgun won't do as much
damage
so something like that she hit him a
bunch of a bun oh that's uh that's how I
like to do it yeah okay Laurie open up
oh sorry I pushed off a little bit
that's fine jugglin oh god oh no elbow
father all right no huh sir tonight hey
hey yeah hey come over here could get
him Oh Gorman no I'm so so far away come
to me that River wall there you go oh oh
come back to her a bag on what kind of
some dad's here all right I hate with a
seabird yep nope nope and he was so
close oh my god and white shoes are back
up two minutes twenty perfect spot
punch punch all right he did one down
two minutes to go for the next one